despite the president's dumpster fire
polling his party scoring some wins in
Kentucky Ohio and Virginia abortion
rights mostly driving the Democrats to
the polls but never mind that the
braggadocious big guy thinking it's all
about him Joe spiking the football
saying democracy won and Maga lost
Politico reports how Biden basked in the
moment making call after call to the
night's Big Winners and how his dorky
staff was sharing dark Brandon memes in
their group chats find her also praising
her boss listen if you look at what um
Cameron did there he spent $30 million
$30 million $30 million trying to
connect uh the governor of Kentucky
Basher to the President right and he
called it a Basher Biden agenda Basher
ran on infrastructure he ran on lowering
costs those are those are the
president's agenda but the president
didn't go out and campaign himself on
that issue but it is rare for a
president it is rare for a president to
go to a state that is and coined by all
of you a deeply Red
State the White House boasting about the
Basher Biden agenda but Joe barely
lifted a finger to help Andy Basher
secure his win as Kentucky governor in
fact the Democrat didn't want anything
to do with Biden Governor's race has
nothing to do with who's in the White
House it has to do with what's going on
in your house it has to do with bringing
in good jobs it's about expanding
Healthcare at the end of the day this
should be about who the best candidate
is with the best plan and the best track
record
all right Dana Pina what happened last
night well lots of things um I do let's
just take Basher Kentucky for example uh
young Governor a pretty popular had a
pretty good approval rating uh abortion
was an issue early on and I think Daniel
Cameron who is a great candidate he's
Attorney General of Kentucky he had
Trump's backing that's a state that
Trump won by like 35 points or something
like that but incumbents are hard to
beat abortion is an issue that's hard to
beat and get out the vote is difficult
you mentioned in the commercial break
about fundraising I don't know the
details in terms of how much was spent
in Kentucky versus others but overall
yesterday Republicans were outspent by a
lot one of the things that happening
that's happening is that small dollar
donors are really strong in the
Democratic party right they you
basically they have this it's called act
blue and you just it's like throwing
seeds into a a field with lots of
fertilizer that you saw out in
California and all of a sudden it's like
oh yeah here everybody's sending their
money in on the Republican side of
things the the GOP Primary has taken a
lot of small dollar donations right also
president Trump's packs take a lot and
some of these campaigns didn't have
enough and Republicans are getting
swamped by planed Parenthood fund not
only the money that Planned Parenthood
has but the organization is superb so
that is one of the things that happened
the other thing that happened is in Ohio
on the abortion amendment is that the
writing of that amendment was so
horrible and I don't know how it was
allowed to go forward it had if you
actually read the whole thing and try to
diagram the sentence you would look like
a mad scientist because it didn't make
any sense but the other thing is there
wasn't enough engagement on the
Republican side so people are thinking
about that that you cannot wait to
engage on your position on abortion what
however you're going to message it
however you're going to talk about it
talking about it is very important so
that is an issue um I won't talk the
whole time here I'll move on but I want
to mention this the Democrats are trying
to get abortion referendums on several
different states that will matter
greatly in the 2024 general election and
that includes Nevada for example Florida
where you would have to get a
60% uh turnout or approval in order for
it to pass what kind of a turnout
motivator is that for Democrats also pay
attention to the young vote they are
organized they are do we saw this in
Wisconsin when they did that special
Supreme Court election that was also
about abortion you had an 88% turnout
rate in the county where the school the
M the main campuses are in Wisconsin
what do you think that's going to look
like in Florida or in Nevada or if they
get one in Georgia so it's a it's a
serious problem that Republicans need to
wrestle with I do think Glenn yunan in
Virginia I thought his messaging on
abortion was the best I had seen on
abortion for his position I think he
worked his butt off u in some places
Republicans were able to win but they
came up short and I for somebody like
Basher who will probably run in 2028 I'm
pretty sure he doesn't want Biden Basher
as his call letters right he'll want to
be bashier on his own independent and
that's what he was trying to say on
Monday so abortion and cash Jessica is
that the story of last night and pot and
pot abortion cash don't forget about our
marijuana um no that's not the only
Story the main headline is Democrats
continue to overperform in the Biden era
just you can't dispute it it is blowing
the polling out of the water um
Republicans haven't really had a good
showing since Trump won in 2016 and they
really and I know that there are a lot
of them you know deeply conservative
people that are coming around to the
idea that Donald Trump loses himself
elections and he loses the people that
he endorses they took the house in 2000
right 20 20 20 yeah two yeah 5 three
seat so remember your no 2022 that was
that was your Red Wave remember when you
said I'm getting a 40 seat wave and then
you got three seats and a George Santos
oh don't remind me okay
anyway um Dana's right the wording on
the amendment in Ohio was funky but
people understood what it meant and
forget often and I think it should be
more of a line of conversation about
this that row was originally about
privacy it was a privacy decision it
wasn't about abortion it is nowhere
listed in it which is why Ruth Bader
Ginsburg herself said that she didn't
think it would hold up forever because
it's not about abortion so that's how
they managed to get it was a 72 ruling
with conservatives siding with the
Liberals because the point is is that a
decision as important as to whether you
are going to carry a pregnancy to term
or not is between you and your doctor
and that's what they ran on in Ohio and
talked about constantly that's how they
got Kansas that's how they got Kentucky
Michigan Etc and the GOP
will not get out of their own way on
this they have found no Avenue to talk
about this like civilized people 58%
think the GOP is too extreme on this and
then you have the new speaker Mike
Johnson sitting up there he's the
sponsor of no less than three bills that
would make us have a National Abortion
ban Andy Basher was successful because
he's a really good governor also how he
managed the floods in Kentucky was one
of the main things that people supported
him for but his most effective ad was a
young girl who was 12 years old when her
stepfather pregnated her she's just
looking into the camera she never
mentions the word abortion it's about
Freedom it's about choice and in the
Ohio bill it's a heartbeat Bill and it
has no rape exception on what planet do
you think people are going to go for
this and this is women and men it's not
just women 20% of trump voters in Ohio
voted to make sure abortion is legal
Glenn yanin did I understand Dana you
saying his messaging was better than
others on this bands turn people off you
cannot talk abor about abortion in that
way each pregnancy is so distinct and it
is so difficult you have pregnancies
that are wanted that you lose a majority
of women who have abortions are people
who have had kids before it's part of
family planning so you look at that girl
12 years old the 10-year-old in Ohio
going to Indiana for health care and
Republicans will continue to lose on
this so
Janine um I look at it uh a little
simpler it it to me it was about um Ohio
Kentucky Virginia Pennsylvania purple
States two red States Democrats winning
and the issue of abortion is one that
Republicans either have to get straight
on or they're going to lose on it and
the way they Lo they can't ignore it
they can't make believe it's not there
so the question is how do you handle it
well it's not really how the Republicans
handle it because right now they don't
have 60 votes in the Senate so stop
trying to pass a federal legislation
it's not going to happen you're creating
unnecessary turmoil for Republican
candidates down the down the ticket the
the the truth is that when um Basher
went out there and he brought and I've
prosecuted those cases with the 12y old
girls and the 10year old girls you know
Cameron who is a great AG supported not
just by Trump but supported by McConnell
he tried to change his you know go go a
little more left it didn't matter women
want freedom and what's going to happen
is that dozens of states are literally
going to put these abortion initiatives
I don't care what you call it privacy I
I don't care they know what they're
reading and they're going to win on that
and Republicans have to understand this
is not an issue they win on this
happened in
2022 it's
2023 and 2024 is right around the corner
and so all you have to do is throw out
that word for Democrats they want to
defend it and it motivates them and it
only helps the Democrats and as for Joe
Biden saying you know with the evidence
is you know I'm strong you know Basher
said it best he said Biden had nothing
to do with my
race correct well I gotta say Democrats
are very lucky that they're running
against a party with principles because
when you have principles you're less
likely to compromise in exchange for
power right so yeah sure Republicans can
win and you'll get lower taxes and a
stronger economy and more security and
less crime but but if that means you're
going to give in on abortion I prefer to
lose on principle I think a lot of
people feel that way damit usually the
opposite power Trump's principle it's
why they were okay with sorus funding
Das that destroyed our cities the
country suffers but they won those seats
it's why the original party of free
speech comes out in favor of censorship
because it suppresses Republican opinion
as disinformation and they win it's why
they don't mind a non-border because
maybe longterm it will help them with
votes more voters um but I you know this
is how the chips fall when you vote reg
regarding abortion if this is how it
happens fine right you can now discuss
it as an act and not a right it's no
longer a constitutional right so you can
have one and you can live with it but we
can still talk about it it's a loss it's
a denial of transformational change it's
a decision for most people I'm not
talking about spefic specifics but for
most people done out of fear but we no
longer have to pretend it's anything
more than that we don't have to have
political discussions about rights
abortion is based on a fear that is
greater than the actual reality and if
you don't believe me talk to somebody
who had a baby and then think about how
they were before they had the baby
that's called a transformational change
right the woman becomes a different
woman than she was before when abortion
was an option and that drives the fear
once you see that you can't unsee it
right it's the best anti-abortion
argument out there and no one is making
it people do have their reasons for
abortions you mentioned a very very
tragic and ugly one but people make
decisions out of their careers or maybe
their relationship the person they're
dating isn't the person they want to
marry um but underneath all that is a
fear of this transformational change and
if you admit that that might actually
move you to maybe a different stance
than you have now now hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else